[Musique]
le déplacement etc et surtout la comédie
parce que c'est une des facettes qui est
très importante
vous êtes avec une station en l'air sur
la tête à genoux
[Musique]
c'est une expérience parce que forcément
on propose souvent des stages de danse
des stages de chant surtout nous au
cabaret mais je trouve que le stage de
cascade c'est très recherché on a
beaucoup de parents qui nous disent mais
c'est génial de faire ça et c'est rare
une vingtaine d'enfants a pu devenir un
cascadeur le temps d'un stage en février
dernier le cabaret organise aujourd'hui
c'est journée à la demande à destination
des entreprises pour les enfants les
adolescents mais aussi les adultes